oh
qui dit antidote dit poison l'un ne va
pas sans l'autre qui dit poison dit
quelques heures quelques minutes voire
quelques secondes à vivre il existe un
poison auquel nous avons tous goûté le
silence rassurez-vous ce qui fait le
poison c'est la dose
j'ai vu vos regard inquiet pourtant les
femmes aurait peut-être besoin qu'on
leur donne un antilopes temps elles ne
sont pas entendus faut-il leur laisser
la parole vous avez sans doute entendu
parler d'autres à winfrey la femme la
plus influente du monde voir la femme la
plus puissante au monde d'après les
médias
aujourd'hui elle est actrice
milliardaire réalisatrice télé écrivain
pourtant elle est issue d'un milieu
pauvre dans sa jeunesse ses camarades de
classe se moquer d'elle car elle portait
des vêtements faits en sac de pommes de
terre
plus tard elle suivi des études en
communication dans le but de faire de la
télévision
mais on le lui refusa et pour des
raisons purement physique on la qualifia
d'inaptes à la télévision oprah winfrey
aurait pu abandonner douté de ses
capacités et même se dire que ce n'était
pas fait pour elle mais elle avait sa
vision elle avait le choix entre la
réaliser ou vivre dans leur gré oprah
winfrey a t-elle avec la seule force de
ses rêves briser le plafond de verre qui
l'empêché d'être sous les projecteurs
ou bien ce plafond s'est-il fissuré au
fil du temps et des tentatives en nous
mettant au défi de le dépasser
la première question qui nous vient à
l'esprit c'est pourquoi des femmes ne
prend-elle pas la parole mais la
question que j'ai envie de vous poser
c'est pourquoi elles prendront la parole
comment et dans quel but est ce que
c'est une affaire
nous les femmes on les regarde d'abord
on les écoute ensuite sois belle et
tais-toi joconde mystérieuse sans voix
ni droits leur dignité est atteinte et
le monde se tait je veux qu'on remplace
le mot égalité dans les écoles par le
mot dignité
le jour où les hommes pourront faire
plusieurs choses en même temps comme
surveiller l'eau des pâtes et les
enfants sans brûler les pattes ou perdre
un enfant
on pourra peut-être parler d'égalité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en réalité nous sommes tous différents
et les exemples ne manquent pas l'homme
n'est ni supérieur ni inférieure à la
femme car la question des hommes et des
femmes se pensent sous l'angle de la
justice car la justice adapte les
différences elles ne les soumet pas aux
normes
mais alors que se passe-t-il si on
accepte le cycle poison le silence donc
la mort alors d'accord c'est une
métaphore
les hôpitaux ne sont pas remplies de
femmes qui n'ont pas parlé ça se saurait
je crois en revanche il existe une
protéine du langage la protéine foxp2
qui seraient présentes en majorité dans
les cerveaux féminins et chez certains
hommes ayant un cerveau féminin au
compteur les femmes utiliserait vingt
mille mots par jour contre seulement
7000 pour les hommes soit près de trois
fois plus alors le don des femmes ce
n'est pas nécessairement d'être de bonne
oratrice mais d'être de bonne
communicatrice alors on fait quoi de la
discrimination positive pour ce soir je
vous propose une méthode en 3 c'est le
premier c est pour changer saisissez
chaque opportunité de prendre la parole
et de vous exprimer
si votre voisin ou un présentateur télé
tient des propos qui vous dérange
répondez lui écrivait lui une lettre
posté une vidéo sur youtube ou instagram
même si vous n'avez pas de retour votre
réaction est la preuve qu'il ya déjà en
vous ce changement
vous avez déjà la volonté de prendre la
parole ce changement n'est pas présent
chez tous les individus
il ya quelques temps sur twitter une
jeune femme se vanter qu'un homme avait
payé son repas et celui de son ami car
je cite les hommes travaillent pour les
femmes
alors je lui ai demandé des précisions
si elles avaient refusé
je n'ai rien de précis si ce n'est
qu'elle était ravie
le deuxième c'est et pour célébrer
chaque opportunité
chaque effort que vous
être pour prendre la parole doit être
célébré mais attention c'est l'effort
que vous célébrez et non pas le résultat
que ce soit un échec ou un succès offrez
vous un bon repas une sortie au cinéma
prenez du temps pour vous votre cerveau
fera automatiquement le lien entre
récompenses et prendre la parole vos
prochaines tentatives ou feront alors
moins peur et votre motivation sera plus
grande
le troisième et dernier c est pour
cultiver le but est d'initier le
processus de changement dont je parle
est plutôt le fait que les femmes n'est
pas accès à la parole est à l'origine
d'une souffrance et cette souffrance ne
peut être libéré que par la compassion
alors je sais que beaucoup d'hommes dans
cette salle ne se sentent pas concernés
par mes propos et se demandent depuis
cinq minutes quand est ce que j'aurai
terminé
pourtant pour ce dernier c'est nous
avons besoin de vous car la compassion
cédiez je souffre à te voir souffrir
mais si mon silence te libère du tien
alors je me tais alors posez votre
smartphone et offrait à votre entourage
la possibilité d'être entendu vous serez
vous-même surpris parce que vous pourrez
tirer de ces conversations
alors aujourd'hui on fait quoi on se
félicite des quotas de femmes ingénieurs
chefs d'entreprise policière peut-être
qu'un jour on ne parlera plus de quota
des femmes et de parité mais de valeurs
de compétence et de complémentarité il
se peut même qu'un jour la parole des
femmes dérange et qu'elle dépasse celle
des autres non pas par leur nombre mais
par leur force
vous voilà averti les femmes
n'attendront pas qu'on les sauve et
qu'on leur donne l'antidote car la
parole ne se donne pas elle se prend
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]